when people are talking about something
It Isn't So Much their position that I'm
trying to imitate as the as the way
they're presenting it I'm just trying to
phonetically recreate the sound of
political sophistication and uh and and
knowing what you're talking about and
oftentimes in in things that I've
written
um whether it's a few good maths or
Sports night or The West Wing uh
there'll be a quick passage uh that'll
go by and you know somebody the studio a
producer someone will say you know gee
no one's going to know uh what these two
people are talking about you know I'll
say that's actually not important that
they do what's important is that the
audience say wow these guys really know
what they're talking about CJ and AP
report out of Gaza says the president
threatened to withhold more than 100
million dollars to Palestinian ngos
unless the chairman handed over mujib
well I'm not going to get into the
details of the Diplomatic exchange
there'll be more on that tomorrow